but yeah i am the pagan priestess you've
never heard of the pagans
uh
i mean i've heard of the
pagans but
what is a pagan priestess
how do i explain this
i don't even know how to articulate it
it's basically the female head
are you
are you a pagan yes you are yes so what
does that mean
what does that mean
i'm affiliated with the pagans
the pagan priestess
how is your life different than
a normal woman's
well when i tell you that i walk through
any neighborhood
that i want in this country
i mean some of the worst places that
you've seen and
i walk freely
nobody bothers you
hmm
even schedule
yeah
yeah
all right jamie lynn
jamie uh where did you grow up where are
you from originally
um
originally from
ken island maryland which is right
across the bay from baltimore i was born
in baltimore my parents moved me over
there when i was very young
i am
like i said i grew up their middle class
wasn't anything real spectacular just
living
um
you had mom and dad yeah yeah my
mother's past my dad lives in ohio
how would you describe your childhood
i'm
normal
a normal single
single parent
home
with an older brother and sister
it was um
trying say the least
what were the roughest parts of it
honestly i'd say school watching my
mother struggle through a divorce
trying to
make it with no job skills
support three kids
no traumatic events in your life as a
kid
no abuse or anything like that yes i was
abused when i was younger
when i was eight by a neighbor and then
i was raped when i was 12.
so that kind of
put me on the
not so much skids just
at a very awkward spot in life yeah
changes a woman forever right yes
what kind of kid were you in high school
i was uh
i was the one that would uh walk in the
front door check in and then go out the
back
so
it was um you finished you graduated it
was normal no i didn't finish
i have a 10th grade education
then i need to uh further
and drugs are part of your life
drugs have been a big part of my life
i've been trying to stay away from them
but it's
easier said than done yeah so
when does that start for you
well
it started this morning and i'm taking
it second by second
you know what i mean
just take it
one step at a time and what's your drug
well
i'm a pilot user so it was anything that
you put in front of me but these days
it's been
up
speed
math that
and where do you stay now you're in skid
row and attend
um
i have a tent i sleep where i can
you know what i mean
a good bit a good bit
i am
but at the same time i can't see
if i have the makeup and the means
i don't like letting myself go
i don't like it
it's happened stuff gets stolen
you leave stuff somewhere
so you got to make do with what you got
you have kids
no
and if i did then i wouldn't they
wouldn't be up for discussion
you know what i mean i know you mean
is this the lowest point of your life
right now
yes and no
yes in some aspects no one others
yes as far as not having a home
a place to stay you don't know how
you're getting your meals from one
minute to the next
and of course i have no idea i'm having
trouble having trouble getting my id so
can't get a job
even if i do manage to panhandle enough
money you can't get a room
so it's
it's hard
it feels like the deck stacked against
you
do you have any friends
down here
not really
down here it's nothing but hustlers and
people trying to take advantage of you
yeah they try to take advantage of you
real bad
you soul have contact with your family
no what family i
do have left
i'm estranged from my sister and
my father i've
lost touch with i don't have a phone i
don't have
any contacts anyhow
you've been in love before you say what
have you been in love before yes
yes
very in love
very in love
um why do you ask no i ask that question
a lot
it's important in people's lives
yes it is when i say that the love of my
life
is
my biggest cheerleader and
also
on his biggest disappointment
at the same time
so
it's hard
he doesn't use and you
you have an addiction
pretty much
does that cause a lot of shame and
i think that
he feels that i'm an embarrassment
and that
i should be able to do better
but some days yeah he's right
other days not so much but
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
what do i worry about
being stuck
never getting out of here never getting
out of here
being crazy
and just
being
not so much insignificant but
it's the word i'm looking for
well yeah i guess insignificant like i
don't matter
just another homeless person on the
street yep
just somebody else fall through the
cracks
yeah and um you're very presentable i
mean you look like
you could be in another part of town not
involved in drugs and this homeless
lifestyle
i was walking down the street to go
brush my teeth this morning and somebody
looked at me and told me to go back to
hollywood yeah what are you doing here
yeah pretty much so
i am
is there something
something positive about this lifestyle
freedom of it the lack of responsibility
there is no freedom to it it's more
restraining if you ask me in my opinion
because you're limited to
the people
around you
you're looked down upon
there's stigma with it there's judgment
now don't get me wrong you meet some of
the
best people that you'd ever want to meet
but at the same time you meet very
desperate people
that their backs are against the wall
they don't always have a choice between
right and wrong but what is the lesser
of the evils
so
you've been on the skid row for how long
since july
since i got here
yes
baltimore
dallas fort worth
and track down here how how has this
lifestyle
changed you you've been doing it for how
long
it's definitely made me more humble
and
it's made me
understand exactly
what i had
and what i'll
probably never have again
not the way that it was
and that's if i even get close to it
which
it has brought me closer to god
i do pray a lot more
i am
i'm grateful for the little things i get
now
things that most people wouldn't think
of
like a warm bed to sleep in or a roof
over your head
where you don't have to worry about
somebody stealing your stuff or
taking advantage of you or
just
flat out
taking advantage
[Music]
do you ever get a room for yourself
um not since i've been here to get away
from it all not since i've been
here tonight maybe i haven't
not since i've been here so when i tell
you that all summer long i was outside
pretty much
that if i wasn't
sleeping
on a bench somewhere
i was in a tent
or walking all night
and um
it's interesting
the way that
your perception changes compared to your
situation
and as you progress through life most
people don't ever get
that drastic of a change
did you once have a life that was that
looked very different than this
extremely different
extremely different
i wasn't rich but
i wasn't down either
as far as i knew i was happy
and
i wasn't extravagant but it was home
and it is a far cry away from what this
is now
what do you think people that are not
playing around with these kind of
drugs in this lifestyle don't understand
about it
it's not so easy to get out no
no
it
it's almost like quicksand
yeah i've compared it to that before
once you're in it
i mean yeah it's possible to pull
yourself out
but at the same time it is such a
knockdown drug out fight
that many people give up
many people give up
it's so much easier to stay stuck then
yep then get out stay stuck and try to
put then to try to pull yourself up and
out
but at the same time
when you got everything stacked against
you working against you it gets tiring
running around in circles
and the treatment you get from the
public or from your families or whatever
i'll put it to you like this
because i had my stuff in a stroller
once i was denied use of a bathroom
i um
i've had people look down on me tell me
to just get away from them
get out of here
it
it's been one thing after another
and like i said it wasn't always that
way
this isn't what you dream of being when
you're a little kid no i'm sure not you
know what did you did you have dreams of
something how old are you me i'm 37.
yeah you probably had dreams of doing
something very different than this yeah
extremely different i am
it's like i woke up one day
and it's what the hell happened
and i understand that i have nobody to
blame but myself
but
at the same time
you know
i know where it went wrong i just
don't like thinking about it
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
was not
taking everything for what it was in
front of me
not paying attention
and
just not
appreciating everything that i did have
when i had it
i took a lot of things and people for
granted in my life
that
some of them still talk to me but
it'll never be the same
you yourself hope of
rebuilding your life
i mean you have to have hope if not then
what's the point of going on just
looking at you it tells me that you do
yeah
yeah what what personality trait do you
do you
have that
can maybe give you an edge and get out
of here
i'm hardheaded and i i honestly believe
that it's not how many times you get
knocked down it's how many times you get
back up
so
resilient if nothing else
and when you piss me off i get spiteful
i do things just to prove you wrong
yeah but if you can channel that anger
into something positive it'll help you
rebuild your life yeah that's the best
revenge you can get yeah no you're
absolutely right about that
i am
i dream of one day standing on my own
two feet
which that was never even a thought for
me
three four years ago
so
i'm working on it though
you know yeah well you don't you don't
look like your typical homeless drug
addict you look like
you know you're
you're beautiful and you're still you
looking at from your feet to your head
you're
you're well put together
you caught me on the right day
that's the god's honest truth but you
need to get your ass out of this
neighborhood yeah off the streets i know
it
which i've been trying to get help
and it's just like i'm being running
around in circles
i almost i'm starting to get suspicious
of help
everyone's looking for help i don't the
people that i see doing it yeah
just they just had a tiny little helping
hand and then they did 99.9 of the work
themselves yeah that's really what i
think it's starting to when i say if i
could get my birth certificate an id
i'd be good i'd be able to get a job get
a car
do anything it's not like i'm
a skillless i'm a waitress by trade
but
food services
you know
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to do
that
i'm just i'm looking for a break
any break
you know it's not
always
that
you want to be around something
as far as like the drugs and everything
else
i walk down the street
and um offered stuff
five ten times within three blocks
it's hard with it being put in front of
your face
but at the same time
i need to be strong enough to say no
so
once i do get
straight and get out of here i just need
to
stay away from
certain elements
because it's too easy for me to go back
too easy for me to go back
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your life
nothing's forever
you need to appreciate what you have
when you have it
take join the people people in your life
not so much the things and possessions
but the people
all right john well thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out here
right now
right now
you